ball four for seven in the three ball
here is lillard tend to shoot lillard
step back you bet it's
game time lillard puts portland in front
[Applause]
how about the move the move was
beautiful
he had nothing the defense played him
perfectly
and all he did was now you're gonna
force me to step into my favorite area
two steps or one step watch this i'm
gonna jump back
and shoot it in your face there's no
more dangerous guy he's
more dangerous as good or dangerous pass
out
for a three oh anthony might have gotten
away with a little push there
now he finds jones underneath for the
finish
and portland goes back up by three with
6.9
left in the fourth man in front of the
run
so here's your double team and watch
what happens
there's the pass on the rotation up
[Applause]
finney smith the inbounds doncic gets
open clean look for three
doncic unable to tie the game and
it was right there for him blazer bench
well it should be that's the correct
call i i know
right now that's a tough call for dallas
to take
but on the replay that we showed from
the baseline area
the ball was off the fronts and out of
bounds
i think luca could not have gotten a
better look here
that's right now you got a fairness
right there
he came right up from below and the ball
was being held
and he hit